I'm joined now in the studio by sevens
cable who is standing in his former
constituency of Twickenham hello sevens
thanks for coming on the program today
now it seems as though the Lib Dem
strategy is the kind of 48% mopping up
the votes of those dissatisfied and
disappointed remain errs with the
promise of a second referendum on the
deal let's just talk about that because
in reality the only thing you can offer
people it's a choice between what to
reason main negotiates and the prospect
of crashing out of the EU if they deal
at all isn't it I think it's more than
that I mean it isn't just the 48%
there's an awful lot of people who voted
to leave who would be very very
concerned if we had an extreme version
of brexit which is what cereza may seems
to be planning in a leaving single
market leaving the customs union
breaking off our research connections
with Europe and and I think we know what
the Liberal Democrats are speaking to is
everybody who is concerned about the
potential damage that could be done by
this so-called how and brexit and we
want to be an effective force in
Parliament arguing against it how about
that specific thought of a second
referendum on the deal
because if you think about it if we're
going to leave the EU in two years then
the referendum is just going to be on to
reason those Deal or No Deal at all
unless the EU member states agree to an
extension which is really very unlikely
is it well we don't know what the world
would be like in two years time but as
you rightly say we could finish out with
a very bad deal or we could finish up
with no deal at all which means crushing
out potentially catastrophic economic
consequences and the Lib Dems say look
you know the public have got to have a
say on something we did vote to leave in
the referendum that's that's for sure
but not the way in which we were going
to leave and the Lib Dems are saying
let's see what happens in these
negotiations but if it is bad and if
there is no deal and the British
probably have got to have another say
become what I'm confused about is what
happens you have another say but then
we're out of the EU I think the European
Union countries will be very pragmatic
and they would accept that if they ought
to British you're rethinking this then
they're not going to be obstructive
about that okay mr. Capel I do wonder if
you've been in politics so long now that
you
you personally are so wedded to the idea
about second referendum have a look at
something
you said back in September at fringe
event at Lib Dem conference when you
said that the idea of a second
referendum is seriously disrespectful
and politically utterly
counterproductive yes no I did say that
in that context which was immediately
after the referendum we just had no we
had to accept that the referendum was
the way it was and that the public voted
the way they did we're now talking about
something totally different we're
talking about getting to the end of the
process of negotiation and let and
having some fallback mechanism so that
we can stop something disastrous
happening I mean actually you know
referendums are not a good way of
deciding these binary in a binary way
these very complex issues but
nonetheless you know that was the way
that the matter has been resolved and
that's the way the matters got to be
corrected okay your leader Tim thyroid
in an interview today says he rules out
doing a coalition were there any other
party do you think that's a bit like me
ruling out going on a date with George
Clooney I mean the authors not really on
the table is it well it could have been
and we're just making it absolutely
clear that it's not something we we want
to do or intending to do well I was a
close well yet you may think so but an
awful lot of conservatives are going
around the doors at the moment saying
the Lib Dems are going to work in a
coalition with labor and labor people
are going around saying you have a
collision with the Tories we're making
absolutely clear that is not on we're
not doing that we want to be an
effective opposition to the government
there is a real danger at the moment of
the Conservatives Teresa most
conservatives winning with the landslide
and doing so in a kind of very kind of
scary atmosphere you know crushing
saboteurs I mean this is making it sound
like Turkey and Russia you know we don't
want that kind of country and we do need
to have a very effective opposition to
what is potentially a very arrogant
government and do you think they're Dems
are realistically capable of forming
that opposition I mean if we need to
kind of get real here you know you've
got nine MPs you around eleven percent
in the polls I mean there's lots of talk
about Lib Dem fight back but are we
getting a bit carried away with it here
well I don't think we're going to win a
landslide but we're certainly going to
on our current position and the question
is how much we improve and I think once
people see the clarity of our position
and the fact that uniquely of the major
parties with we have been consistent of
principled on the issue of Europe and
brexit and we have a good platform of
other policies - I think our support
will increase and key I mean given the
way the British voting system works is
not you know the average share of the
boat is not the key factor it's whether
you can win in your particular
constituencies and we have a solid base
of support in many parts of the country
including man how you forgive some of my
skepticism here because I do remember in
the 2015 general election being spun a
line by the Lib Dems that you're going
to do much better than the share of the
weight in the polls and what happened
there and know it happened know that
2015 was a disastrous election but we
now have a following wind we had a
headwind in 2015 it could be very
different
it could be very different and this week
of course your leader Tim Farron was
forced to clarify that he doesn't think
that being gay is a sin he's also
wrestled with the laws over abortion as
a committed Christian if you are trying
to pitch yourself trying to win back
those votes of their kind of liberals if
you like who perhaps feel they don't
have a natural home in labour all the
conservatives at the moment it's Tim
power and really the man to do it yes
and we are a Liberal Party in that wider
social sense and he's voting record is
as of a liberal MP and then the problem
he has as an individual and it's true of
a lot of evangelical Christians and
Roman Catholics is that their religious
faith has a certain approach these
problems but there are also public
figures who have to represent their
constituencies which are much more
diverse and I think Tim accepts and I
think you know many highly motivated
Christians accept that when they're in
public life they've got to reflect the
people that they represent and he's done
so and he's done so in a very liberal
way there's nothing to detract from our
broader message about being a socially
liberal party so he's effectively you
might say out of step with what no he
has a personal faith and I respect
people
who have a personal face he's struggling
with his conscience as a lot of
Christians and indeed Muslims and others
our that he is when it's come to the
crunch to the vote voting for gay
marriage voting on these issues he has
voted consistently with a in a liberal
way along with the rest of our party and
you believe that's because he wants to
put the views of the people he's
representing above his own personal
views yes and it's difficult because if
you are a true you know if you have real
faith that is not an easy thing to do
and I think one has to respect people
who are grappling with their faith in
the way that he is now
we're talking a lot about the election
of course and as you'd expect but I'm
also keen to get your thoughts on the
economy at the moment as well now you of
course were one of the few people who
sort of predicted the last financial
crash before it happened and I'm just
wondering what your view is on the
current economic prospects of the UK
because we have brexit looming personal
debt levels are still very high could we
be seeing another recession on the cards
I'm not predicting recession but there
are some very deep weaknesses in the UK
economy I mean we did recover from the
depths of the financial crisis I was
part of the government that helped to
make that recovery but but you know
there are some fundamental weaknesses we
have very low productivity which is why
wages are low and we did make a start
when I was in the government of
promoting apprenticeships and industrial
strategy but it's a long term task we
have a temporary kind of boom taking
place at the moment
which is largely fired by personal debt
and heavy borrowing and that is not
sustainable the government finances are
not in great shape and because brexit
will almost certainly produce an
economic slowdown not this survey
recession that's certainly a slowdown
this will affect government revenue it
will make the the managing of the budget
even more difficult public services in
areas like schooling and health are
desperately stretched and we are going
to have to provide more funding for that
so this is the dilemma that any party in
government is now going to face and it's
not easy our politicians grappling with
those issues do you think well I think
we're beginning to see in the early days
of campaign a recognition by the
tourists to start with and indeed by
other party
that we're going to have to face you
know higher taxation as well as in a
continuing discipline of a public for
now and so what I would like to see
actually and I wanted this to happen and
the coalition years is a very clear
distinction between borrowing to cover
the overdraft of the government and
borrowing for public investment you know
building up an infrastructure in our
broadband railways housing and the
government could be getting on with that
borrowing at very very low rates of
interest in order to build up the
country and they keep more productive
than this Tory government isn't doing it
so you you mentioned there that the toys
are starting to grapple with the idea of
higher taxation would you support higher
taxation well I think it's going to have
to happen whoever is in government and
the question is how you do it and making
sure you do it in a fair way I mean
where I would start is some of the
changes that the Conservatives are
brought in since we left the coalition
them and why on earth are we cutting
corporation tax it's well well below the
average of developing im9 pro-business I
mean I want to see business investing
but all that's happening is that
businesses are pocketing the money and
they're sitting on it they're not
investing in it because of all the
uncertainty around brexit that we need
to make the UK an attractive place
prospective I want I want written to be
an attractive place to invest in but
that is unnecessary and it is very very
expensive so you support Jeremy Corbyn
then in saying that corporation tax
should be looked at well certainly on
that particular point I'm not sure I'd
go along with all of jeremy corbyn's
ideas on tax but on that yes definitely
now and before you go I'm quite
interested to know you've had two years
away from politics now have you found it
have you been filling your time if you
take up gardening are you watching box
sets into the small hours not gardening
no I'm not great in the garden
but I've been writing books I've got a
novel appearing in august-september I'm
working universities including my local
university and Twickenham and the London
School of Economics is what you do in
your downtime I still give them up to my
weekly dancing lesson I love that and do
a lot of cycling walking doing the gym
weight training all those things so now
I'm very active and hopefully fit weight
training I love that I'm kind of
enjoying it that much though otherwise
you won't be back for more happens
thank you very much